and master Randy Schekman please
speaking hello this is Adam Smith from
noble media in Stockholm yeah we have
this tradition of recording very short
interviews with new laureates would you
be when he's taught for a few minutes
Gort thank you very much indeed well
first of all congratulations on the
award
thank you thank you um what were you
doing when the call came well I was
sleeping
it's it was you know quarter after 1:00
in the morning here and I just come back
from from Frankfurt yesterday where I
spent a week and the meeting and so I
was quite exhausted but of course I was
aware of but what happens in the morning
so as soon as the phone rent started
ringing my wife yelled out there it is
there it is and I sized up things and
picked up the phone and there was corn
Hanson so it was a thrill of a real
thrill what was your first action after
the call after the call well I danced
around with my wife and repeatedly said
oh my god oh my god and then then I
called my father my 86 year old father
who has been hoping for this for many
years and he was he was shaken but the
thrilled I called my two children Joel
and Lauren and got them out of bed and
they were excited that's nothing
now there's celebrations all over the
country yeah people always joke that the
Ottoman Nobel Prize gets you a parking
space at Berkeley yeah right right
that's uh I did in fact when I was the
chairman of the biochemistry Division I
negotiated with two young faculty who
were moving from MIT and who were very
concerned about their opportunity to
have parking permits for themselves as
assistant professors and is a formal
letter of offer I assured them that they
not only could pay for parking but if
they happen to win a Nobel Prize that
get their parking for free
I am a they claim that that was really
the deeply the the part of the contract
that really filled the deal for them
some unusually it's an unusual incentive
to work hard you are credited with doing
the initial work that took our
understanding of vesicle traffic from a
purely descriptive to the beginnings of
a mechanistic understanding and that
understanding has taken a lot of time to
achieve yeah so um yes well the I think
I to begin with I wanna I want to credit
George Pilate who really pioneered the
field of cell biology by developing the
techniques of electron microscopy to
visualize membranes within human self
and and it was his genius to realize to
appreciate how proteins that are going
to be exported from cells are assembled
in a kind of an assembly line process
inside the cell and when I began my
laboratory in 1976 in is really around
the same time when Jim Rossum began his
laboratory at Stanford we conceived of
two very different approaches to try to
identify the machinery responsible for
for this mechanism and I used a
technique of classical genetics to make
mutations in cells that define the
pathway and Crossman used a very
complementary biochemical process to
reconstitute the pathway in vitro and
over a period of years as we compared
notes sometimes collaboratively
sometimes competitively it became clear
though that he and I were working on
many of the same proteins that's in many
of the same genes and proteins and so
that that synthesis between the two sets
really convinced us that we were on the
right Turner the project on as I did
last question how do you feel about the
onslaught of press attention that's
about to arrive
the onslaught of attention that's about
to read yeah yeah well III don't know
what to what to expect of course around
this time of year I'm always reminded
this could happen and in fact I just
returned from Germany where I got
another award the Otto Herbert prize and
the whole time people were saying well
we'll see what happens on Monday so I
guess I was sort of primed for this
today although I came back from Europe
yesterday so I'm I'm pretty pretty
jet-lagged yes but I imagine you'll be
living on the high of it for some time
yeah oh yeah I'll be awake today well I
wish you a really splendid day and once
again congratulations thank you for
talking to us and I look forward to
talking again soon thank you thank you